the red room gave an orphaned girl the
deadly skills that turned her into the
black widow
and it took one of america's most
patriotic heroes and brainwashed him
into becoming the lethal winter soldier
for the twisted history of the red room
though those two characters are only the
beginning
in the continuity of the comics the red
room dates back to at least world war
ii here in the real world though the red
room didn't make its first appearance
until the late 90s which is pretty
surprising when you consider that black
widow its most famous student
had been a major character in the
avengers for about 30 years at that
point
before shadows and lights number one hit
the shelves with a story that expanded
on natasha's true past
black widow's origin was relatively
simple at least by comic book standards
before she was a superhero she was a
super villain she fought iron man back
in her first appearance and before that
she was just natalia romanova
aka natasha romanov the star ballerina
in the world famous bolshoi ballet
and married to a military pilot named
alexey shostakov
when alexi died in the line of duty
natalia signed up with the kgb
using her finally honed physical skills
and knack for martial arts to train as
an assassin
she took the name black widow because
she somehow knew that americans were
terrified of spiders and
because you know she was literally a
widow except
that she wasn't for one thing alexi had
never actually died the kgb had faked
his death to turn him into the red
guardian the soviet counterpart of
captain america
that made things pretty awkward the
first time he was reunited with his wife
a not so happy event that came when he
fought both black widow and her new
boyfriend
hawkeye another misleading thing about
black widow's original backstory is that
it later turned out that natalie had
never actually been a ballerina
those were false memories implanted
during her training leaving us with a
pretty compelling question
if that wasn't actually black widow's
origin what was
one of the more interesting pieces of
the red room puzzle came in uncanny
x-men number 268.
the story is a team-up starring
wolverine that takes place in two
different eras
one half of the story happens in the
present day of 1990 when wolverine and
black widow team up to take on the evil
ninjas of the hend who are stirring up
trouble in magipur
the second half of the story takes place
49 years earlier in 1941 when wolvey
teams up with captain america to well
also fight the hand back then however
there was
one more wrinkle to the story the
trouble being stirred up was in the form
of a young girl that was kidnapped from
moscow by baron strucker
her name natalia rominova the girl who
would grow up to be the black widow
if you've been paying attention to the
dates you might have already caught on
to a pretty notable quirk to this story
the widow was a young girl
somewhere around 10 years old judging by
the art
in 1941 and she was still out there
fighting bad guys as an avenger
50 years later looking like she was
maybe in her early 30s at most
that's not all that unusual in the
marvel universe but unlike the
characters with whom she shared that
story
the widow doesn't have a mutant healing
factor and she didn't spend years frozen
in a block of
ice to explain the apparent discrepancy
dancers tend to age
pretty gracefully but there was clearly
something more going on with her
backstory to explain her lasting youth
unlike most of marvel's main characters
black widow doesn't
actually have a definitive set in stone
origin story
that's especially odd when you consider
that they literally published a comic
called black widow deadly origin back in
2010
she's maintained an air of mystery for
over 50 years
largely because her training involved
the red room altering her memories to
suit their own sinister purposes
the facts go a little something like
this in 1928
baby natalya was rescued from a burning
building in stalingrad by ivan petrovic
ivan was told by natalia's previous
caretaker that little natalia was a
romanov
a name which naturally hinted at a
possible connection to russia's lost
royal family
who were seemingly all executed 10 years
prior in the russian revolution
that connection however would never be
fully explored
instead despite ivan's protests natalia
was declared an orphan in 1940
and on the order of joseph stalin
himself sent to a new training facility
where she proved to be so adept at
learning to kill
that the hand tried to steal her away
and wolverine had to get involved
the weird thing is despite his
well-chronicled tendency to adopt young
women as a surrogate father figure
he left her in the care of the kgb along
with her 27
sisters while she would become its most
successful product natalia romanova was
certainly not the only young girl
trained in the deadly arts of
assassination by the red room
and its masters in the soviet union
sinister department x
instead she was one of 28 students aka
widows all of whom were orphaned girls
who had the falsified memories of being
dancers for the bolshoi ballet
the architect of this brainwashing was
department x leader vasily karpov
under his direction department x
recruited a psychotechnologist
named grigor chilensoff who had invented
the technique of implanting false
memories
together with a programmer known only as
professor rachenko who later defected to
the united states
he implanted the red room students with
their false memories designed to turn
the girls into
sleeper agents who could pass undetected
in other countries
unfortunately there was a pretty big
flaw in the program
the process itself was torturous and the
results
weren't quite as undetectable as they
wanted especially since the conflicting
memories would sometimes try to assert
themselves at the same time
leading to the widows giving multiple
answers to the same question
the mental modifications weren't the
only ones though
the red room's staff also featured
lumida kudrin a chemical scientist and
geneticist
her work resulted in the drug treatments
that gave black widow her unnaturally
long lifespan
as well as causing a biological response
that would prevent the women of the red
room from ever giving birth because
we wanted warriors not mothers she also
designed a pheromone treatment to keep
the trainees docile
programming them to be unable to attack
their superiors should they ever get the
urge to rebel
there was another notable member of the
red room's faculty although calling him
a member of the staff is
pushing it he was another one of comrade
karpov's pet projects and he was
responsible for putting natalya and the
others through
a vicious round of advanced combat
training he was a pretty effective
teacher too
although that's to be expected after all
he learned to fight from captain america
his name of course was james buchanan
barnes better known at the time
as the winter soldier karpov was the one
who'd fished bucky out of the ocean
after his presumed death in 1945. using
the same technology that he'd employed
to implant false memories into the black
widows
he erased bucky's old patriotic
personality and turned him
into a mindless ultra-efficient killing
machine
while both were under the purview of
department decks the winter soldier
program
and the red room were kept separate with
bucky's side gig as a combat instructor
being their only real crossover
there's a reason for that too the red
room was focused exclusively on women
except of course for the one time that
it wasn't for a brief
period the red room experimented with a
counterpart to the black widow program
involving boys in keeping with the
arachnid naming convention these agents
were code named
wolf spiders and they received similar
training and conditioning
considering that the red room's most
prominent graduate wound up defecting to
america where she joined both shield
and the avengers it might surprise you
to learn that the wolf spider program
was apparently even
less successful the wolf spider program
only produced a single graduate
nico constantine rather than send him on
missions the russian government simply
scrapped the project
and sent nico to a siberian gulag where
they dumped all of their super powered
problems
it was there decades later that he
crossed paths with bucky who trained him
as well
the exact circumstances of his dismissal
were never actually revealed other than
bucky
mentioning that he was psychotic after
his conditioning but it was established
that
unlike the black widows he never got the
chemical treatment that slowed his aging
one of the most notable other graduates
of the red room was yelina bulova
the big difference this time around
though was that elena didn't go through
the mental conditioning that her
predecessor had
in fact her fanatical devotion to the
cause came naturally
on paper her scores exceeded natasha's
and her training cultivated a talent for
spycraft and assassination
honing her into a living weapon to the
point where she was officially given the
black widow code name
needless to say this brought her into a
conflict with her predecessor as she
attempted to take her place
permanently the irony was not only that
jelena would never be the only black
widow but that she wasn't even the only
elena bulova
in an effort to cut through the
time-consuming process of rounding up
athletic orphans
the red room began embarking on a new
tactic cloning their best operatives and
just
programming their brains directly rather
than overwriting existing memories
after discovering the truth about her
own origin a clone of natasha that had
activated after the genuine article's
apparent death
began to work against the program the
natasha clone began to use the yelina
clones for her own purposes
and in the ultimate insult she killed
the real yelina in the process to make
things easier
it even happened off panel one of the
more recent graduates of the red room is
nadia van dyne whose origin story
reveals that if the red room couldn't
find enough orphans to train
they'd just make a few of their own
nadia is the daughter of hank pym
the original ant-man and maria trevia
his first wife who was introduced in a
flashback
all the way back in 1963. in that story
it was revealed that she'd been
kidnapped and killed on their honeymoon
leaving hank
understandably enraged and heartbroken
over 50 years later
it was revealed that maria's kidnapping
was faked and that she'd stayed alive
long enough to give
birth to her daughter nadia who was
given to the red room as their latest
project nadia had apparently inherited
her father's genius
and the red room leaned into that rather
than simply manufacturing a super spy
nadia's branch of the red room was
focused on an attempt to essentially
create
mad scientists hoping to control the
next generation of minds brilliant
enough to do things like build iron man
armor or
time machines to that end the red room's
trainers encouraged nadia by
revealing her parentage unfortunately
for them telling nadia about her famous
american superhero father had the side
effect of fueling her desire to escape
which turns out to be pretty easy when
you have access to size changing pin
particles and the brains to use them
after her escape nadia was mentored by
her stepmother janet van dyne better
known as
the wasp inspired and nurtured for the
first time by someone who didn't want to
use her brilliance for world domination
nadia took both janet's super heroic
identity and her last name for her own
changing her name to nadia van dyne and
leaping into action
as the all-new wasp the dreamy
hallucination of age of ultron isn't the
only time we've seen the red room in the
marvel cinematic universe pre-black
widow and natasha romanov isn't the only
graduate who's stepped into the
spotlight either
decades before nat took her undercover
job as tony stark's personal assistant
in iron man 2
agent peggy carter crossed paths with
the red room prototype
dottie underwood played by bridget regan
dottie was one of the primary
antagonists of agent carter a spy who
infiltrated peggy's life in order to
eventually take her out for the russian
government
even by the standards of the red room
the glimpses we see of her training were
especially harsh
in 1937 a young dottie killed her only
friend in a sparring match
ordered by her trainer to choke her to
death in a promising display
of her lethal talents needless to say
dottie wasn't particularly well adjusted
as an adult and her fixation on peggy
was packed with moments that were as
full of danger as they were of sapphic
subtext
you don't want this visit on the record
which means you're probably going behind
someone's back
how naughty check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about the marvel cinematic
universe are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one